tout ça devrait point que là c'est
vraiment un cancer des cancers de la
prostate ce médecin spécialiste en a
traité des milliers avec au fil des ans
des résultats de plus en plus
encourageante concerne la prostate est
de loin le cancer le plus fréquent qu'un
diagnostic chez les hommes au canada et
c'est le troisième tueur comme cancer
chez les hommes
eh oui si le cancer de la prostate est
pris à temps les chances de guérir les
hommes sont au dessus de 90 %
en fait le taux moyen de survie des
patients après cinq ans atteint
aujourd'hui 95% et même 100%
lorsqu'il n'ya aucune métastase par
contre lorsque le camp c'est assez
répandue ça se complique
c'est d'ailleurs un cancer de ce type
qui a terrassé le policier jack layton à
l'âge de 61 ans un cancer dépisté trop
tard le dépistage ou la détection
précoce nous permet de trouver les
cancers dans la grande majorité des gens
à des stades beaucoup plus tôt beaucoup
plus d'opportunités de guérir
aujourd'hui on combat avec la chirurgie
bien sûr mais aussi avec la
chimiothérapie la radiothérapie
l'hormonothérapie et d'imagerie médicale
d'une grande précision
résultat même s'il compte pour 20% des
cancers chez l'homme et les représente à
peine 10 % de la mortalité par cancer
une statistique on peut encore améliorer
avec le recours à la médecine
personnalisée
il faut qu'on adapte le traitement est
pas juste dire mais on essaye sort et en
attendant 3,4 me voir si ça fonctionne
c'est la proche du passé la nouvelle
approche c'est vraiment décès d'un
comprendre le cancer proulx visé avec le
meilleur traitement pour ce patient
particulier j'étais très confiant cet
homme vit avec un cancer de la prostate
depuis 19 ans il a connu plusieurs
rechutes dont la dernière l'a laissé
avec de nombreuses métastases il y à un
nouveau protocole de recherche qui est
arrivé pour pouvoir aller cibler
directement les métastases
depuis le tout premier jour il s'est
efforcé de rester positif c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on combat le cancer de la
prostate
ma réaction je me suis dit je vais m'en
sortir
j'ai toujours dit je vais m'en sortir et
je le répète encore aujourd'hui je vais
continuer de me sortir ici non marron
d'un radio canada montréal